list of things that I think men should never do
starting off with number one-cooking
if you have a woman then I think that she should do it
okay personally, I leave that up to me
unless it's the grill
unless it's like a steak you got the meat
I'll do everything else
number two-doing their laundry
I know some of y'all are gonna come for me
but I just don't think men should have to
cause they're not good at it
they don't know how to fold
they leave it in the dryer for too long
and then when they take it out
it's all wrinkled just
just leave it up to us woman
okay
No. three-decorating
so sorry
those neon signs gotta go
the flags with your sports thing
you know I think that us women
we have an eye for it leave it to us
No.4 buying groceries
or preparing or planning what we're gonna eat for the week
cause if you leave it to a man
they're probably gonna be cooking you beef
just beef.
no sides no greens
just beef
No. 5 dusting
I don't think any man should ever be seen dusting with those little things
I just it doesn't sit right in my brain
okay that
no explanation needed there
No. six mopping
I don't think I've ever seen a guy mop
and for good reason I think men should be allowed to vacuum
but leave the mopping up to me
No. 7 putting laundry away
not sure why
but it's just not built into their brains
to know that
the dish towels and the bathroom towels are two very separate things
leave that up to the woman
okay
I understand that all men should know how to do all these things
but I don’t think they should have to do them